part of NFL Network's coverage all week
long includes my friend the three-time
Super Bowl champion Willie McGinest good
to see you sir oh well how are you I
asked you that question you sat down
you're like just like everybody else
yeah a little somber man a little shock
in shock you know I think it was
shocking for everybody I was at the Pro
Bowl actually and we're getting ready
you know to start the game right when
the news hit and I think everybody was
kind of saying I hope this isn't real
right you know what we're hearing and
when the final news came through man it
was it was it was a little devastating
I'm assuming you know Kobe you've met
him several times you're mr. Long Beach
Poly and obviously mr. USC you have
spent so many years in the public eye in
Southern California just like he he did
I can't get I can't believe we're
talking about him in past tense what was
your relationship like with coach almost
cool with Kobe not like we hung out
without all the time but he was the LA
of course iconic figure not just LA but
globally I would say right and I was a
season ticket holder when he came to LA
so I watch pretty much his entire career
watched him kind of transition from that
Philly guy to that la / Philly guy cuz
you know he was still an East Coast
diehard Philadelphia still I mean he's
Sileo to this you know right and just
watching him transition and pretty much
become acclimated to LA and become one
of the the greatest players in any sport
and just watching his tenacity what he
was made of and I was thinking about
that on the way to the show because I
knew we were gonna talk about it you
could take what Kobe had and you can
apply it in any sport football baseball
whatever you boxing because he had that
it about him to make other players
better raised a level of their game the
tenacity that killer instinct is why
they call him the mama wanted ad Elias
you know right and just what he brought
to the game and how that kind of
transferred off the field and it I mean
I don't know he just did so much for not
only sport but for people where I mean
where does he rank in the Los Angeles
sports panting
and I asked that question fully knowing
what you said he was a kid from from
Philadelphia that Jerry West acquired
and Jerry West as the saying goes and
the story goes that he's told many times
in the last 24 hours
he tried him out Michael Cooper was was
the defender in the tryout and Jerry
West needed only to see a couple minutes
he said he's better than virtually every
player we have on now and he's a kid
that started talking about gonna be
better than Jordan and here you all said
an organization with Kareem and magic in
the show time I do remember that maybe
some Los Angeles sports fans were like
who does this kid think he is and now
he's mr. Los Angeles he was and
especially because he came out of high
school so that's what that's that that's
what when you look at a young kid he was
a kid coming into a man's league and the
way he came in
the confidence he had the confidence
they had it him right you got to give a
lot of credit to Jerry West for getting
Kobe that wasn't his initial team you
know and to see what he had in him
knowing kind of like some of these other
great coaches when they could see and
kind of assume or know what this kid is
what this guy's gonna be later on and
what do you become I think it's pretty
phenomenal and just to be able to share
some of his life and be a part and be a
season ticket holder to be at those
games and just to watch them and then
interact with him you know those times
you were able to see him outside of
basketball well what he's saying it just
hover say so the first thing we always
say was what's up champ you know he was
a fan of Bill Belichick in the Patriots
he spoke to the team before what do you
mean when the claim no not when I was
playing okay I left okay and Belichick
was a big fan of him because he pretty
pretty much embodied everything we did
you know our team did and that's the
first thing we would say what's up champ
how you doing we laugh then of course he
had girls I have three daughters so we
you know it always got into that and
then I'm he's he's a polarizing
superstar so you're not gonna sit there
and talk to him for a hour but he would
always make time Willie McGinest here on
the Rich Eisen show
all right let's uh let's talk game
predictions the big game again is gonna
be available in 4k on Sunday on DirecTV
what do you thinks gonna happen in this
game well the Megan's dad I'm still
formulating and you're not allowed to
formulate I'll make a great match up I'm
glad I'm glad I'm glad these two teams
yes out of the last four teams ended up
being in the UH been in the Super Bowl
because I think it's a it's a great
matchup I think you talk about two
physical teams well
one team is going to try to beat you up
in the trenches the 49ers they play a
certain style in the run game and
another defense and another team that is
physical but they can beat you in a lot
of different ways offensive ly and
they've gotten way better on the
defensive side of the ball it's just
gonna be interesting to see if Kansas
City comes in and gets a lead how that
would change things for to 49ers we'll
see a different offensive game plan
they'll have to adjust there may have to
get away from the run a little bit Jimmy
G may have a little more to say well
you'd have to say it would have to be
two scores like two touchdowns 10 points
14 points I mean most heard most dirt
has been recently and I know again you
know the Chiefs defense is definitely
improved over the second half of the
season and certainly in the playoffs
when you hold Derrick Henry to what they
held he'll say what everyone else is
saying then they're obviously they're
playing well against the run but most
'red has been getting first down per
touch you know in these playoffs so
you'd have to say for for them that
potentially panic because that's what
they would have to do to get out of
their game plan 14 nothing right 17 no
absolutely not 10 question because the
Chiefs will run the ball as well and a
5/8 yard pass is just like a run to the
Chiefs but they're so fast right they
strike so fast and I think if you watch
the game against the Chiefs and the
Titans dear Kerry was a factor early on
but once they got ahead and they start
to score you couldn't handle ball off
anymore because you were gonna you're
playing from behind you have to catch up
and I know you want to be patient I know
you want to be consistent in your
game plan but a team that can go down
and continuously get in strike the same
way you got it you gotta keep up
you got to play keep up so I'm trying to
follow you as you're formulating you're
using Rich Eisen show space IO to work
around Earth your game theory right now
so how do the Chiefs get those points
early it really is mahomes this is I'm a
Holmes game
it's Andy Reid Emma Holmes so what's
important I played against Andy Reid in
2004 in a Super Bowl
yes what's really interesting about Andy
Reid is he's gonna come out with a
script 15 plays whatever it is right and
it's gonna be tempo it's gonna be motion
shift it's gonna give you a lot and he's
gonna try and see what type of defense
you're in and if you're not ready for it
and you panic or you have mental errors
it's gonna turn into touchdowns not big
plays touchdowns and he does that not
only to identify what the defense is in
but also just to get his offense going
so I think that's the tough part and you
got Salah on the other side the
defensive coordinator for the 49ers who
plays on predominantly play zone so I've
been saying for the last few weeks
against this team you cannot sit in a
zone they got too many weapons they'll
figure it out they'll pick you apart
you've got to mix it up you got to be
able to get pressure you got to kind of
keep Pat mahomes off-balance and if you
don't Andy Reid knowing what you're in
it's gonna be a long day so I'm
interested to see the adjustments that
the 49ers defense will make well I don't
know if you heard my DirecTV 4k game
prediction okay the way I let into this
so your game prediction would be right
now on the Monday before the game I
think I'm a ride with the with the with
the AFC the Chiefs Chiefs
okay there's a couple people that are
somewhat in our audience right now
nodding an agreement or clapping that's
fine you may do them okay
the other nice hair full of people up it
Willie McGinest here on the Rich Eisen
show in a few minutes I have left with
you here there's many different ways I'm
gonna ants I could ask this question so
it's just gonna come straight through
the front door do you get chargers
season tickets when Tom Brady shows up
to play
haha willing uh if that happens I think
there are a lot of people that would get
charger season tickets if Tom Brady how
likely is that to happen I'm not sure
I'm honestly not sure I haven't had a
conversation I think Tom's gonna do
what's best for him and his family I
would love to see him return to the
Patriots and finish out his career there
and I'm sure they're gonna do everything
possibly to try to make that happen
but the reality is they're superstars
and players like myself that have left
and went to other organizations before
Tom it has to be right all the pieces
got to fit the resources have to be
there how badly has to be held happy
about it
how about Southern California new
stadium Keenan Allen Mike Williams
hunter Henry listen Gordon or how about
how about that as as your father George
oh yeah I mean about that that sounds
good
there's only one thing he lived in LA
yes
he built the beautiful home and he sold
his home to dr. dre knee left oh yeah
and I'm saying this for a reason because
his wife doesn't like living in LA in
California so that could play a back I'm
just saying that Kay that could possibly
play a wife happy life I know that for
sure but he's a baby for two years if he
says baby let's just do it for two years
I don't because you told me you told me
don't pay attention to the real estate
in this whole thing the real estate
maneuvers there's a lot of things that
factor in his family it's like like you
said your wife um the resources the
different things that you wanted you
know that you want to accomplish there's
a lot of things that factor in tom tom
is not that easy
there's complicated there's a lot of
things business yeah I know the business
of course is a TV 20 beats world that's
going on you look very healthy and so
just tell him to stay Willie call them
up and say Johnny it's that easy I think
all the fans like yourself we want
understand of course and and Bob Kraft
is fan number one and I'm sure he's
gonna but it when it all comes down to
it the roster considerations if that is
an important thing for you cannot be
dressed before the contract the contract
has to come first with the new league
year they can't go and make the moves
and make it more attractive for Tom
unless he wait about New England yes
well they made it attractive remember
they had Josh Gordon he you know he had
a relapse they had a B he lost his mind
so bait bait they had the pieces in
place right and maybe we would be
talking about different teams if those
guys could have stay put but it you know
it didn't happen so you know here we are
all right and I appreciate you coming
here man you're you're one of my
favorites at Willie McGinest
on Twitter and Instagram and you're part
of the whole extravaganza certainly on
Sunday right now we do know some guys do
it without doing more Willie Willie it's
not this year no Willie Willie everybody
Willie McGinest good to see you here sir
you've checked him on NFL Network all
week and all of us will be together on
Sunday for NFL game day morning for more
of the Rich Eisen show tune - audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV for free on BR
live or download the Rich Eisen show app